and so now so it's like it's shannon got
knocked out
chugs got sent packing so rachel's with
brad
there's two girls who are about to come
in but what i'm more keen on
is apparently hugo says something
that really pisses off everybody no way
yeah damn and in the preview he's like
well
i've not been malicious yeah and that's
in today's episode yeah and then sharon
is like well
i don't care if you've not been
malicious it's mean and then faze like
then he starts crying because he feels
so bad and fey's like
i don't care if he's upset he can [ __ ]
off
damn so shit's getting spicy well i
think we have the clip
oh yeah let's ruin it let's ruin it
right now so if you haven't seen it
you're going to see it right now
yes sorry nobody's going to edit
no wait no no no no no no no no no i
can't [ __ ] turn it off
oh man do we have it or not
okay we're in okay cash is gonna go
stick his head into the [ __ ] ground
like no no i don't wanna see it
here's the thing is that like i don't
know i feel like you
if even if you know what happens these
are so much fun to watch oh yeah
no 100 it's the most fun show to watch
it's it's
it's been great it's been great yeah i
think this is going to be a really
strong
season it seems like they're bringing in
the right people
if you're just listening to this they
basically he says that
fakeness is the biggest turn off and
then it punches in on fae who's like
got fake boobs fake lips big eyebrows
fake everything yeah
yeah and she's like oh
what you what you mean by that damn
all right let it rip bro
holy [ __ ] why does he keep your opposite
why does he keep making eye contact yeah
leggy blonde not fake
right chloe tell them what my type is
yeah a girl who doesn't have big fake
boobs right
right no no a natural a natural leggy
blonde
i didn't write natural i wrote not fake
that's the way i prefer to phrase it
chloe what kind of lips do i like real
ones
yeah not fake
damn damn
come on how can you be this dumb
oh it stops damn damn
that's crazy that's the perfect
screenshot that thumbnail right there
wow that's cool every dude is like what
are you doing dude
shut up shut the [ __ ] up so are they
coupled by this point
oh hugo still no he's still with chloe
he's still with chloe right right okay
yeah i mean
that's to be fair now i see why he
became a teacher
this [ __ ] was raising his hand
first all the time yeah
just too eager to speak there man what
and what is the point why just
why i keep hammering at home chloe my
type please
read it for the group please he got the
chalk
and a blackboard and it just like it
took over like he just
the party guy hugo went out the window
and mr hugo came back
it's like right class he's defining
everything too
yeah not fake so that means no
injections no silicone at all no fake
eyebrows i'm talking natural
right everyone what would we
unequivocally agree
is phase silicon right right
how do you put silicon in the body any
injections needles
surgery if you've done
any of these things
you are commensurate you are not my type
you are not my type and who
in here class has some of those things
can we get an example
who's a good example that's right fake
is very